in April the Bureau of Labor Statistics
issued its first jobs report since the
corona virus pandemic overwhelmed the US
the new data say that US employers shed
700 and 1,000 jobs in March change in
non-farm payrolls went negative for the
first time in 113 months the
unemployment rate also rose to four
point four percent from a 50-year low of
3.5% but it's still unlikely that these
losses show the full impact of the
crisis for the most recent jobs report
it's capturing the labor market before
the worst of the corona virus pandemic
took hold in the United States and
before many states acted to restrict
movement and close non-essential
businesses Laden March a different
metric initial jobless claims shot to
record highs then the next week six
point six million people filed claims
economists say that these numbers
foreshadow a coming surge in
unemployment here's how to read the
March jobs report in light of the
shutdowns
like nearly all such jobs reports the
March 1 was based on surveys that look
at the week that includes the 12th of
the month in March 2020 that was the 8th
through the 14th this month survey was
taken before many cities and states shut
down businesses to fight the spread of
the corona virus New York State
announced on March 20th
that non-essential businesses would
close that weekend more states and
cities issued orders throughout the week
and on March 30th governor's from
Maryland Washington DC and Virginia
issued stay at home orders to by April
1st the majority of states had issued
some version of a stay at home order if
the broad shutdowns that we're seeing
now continue we're gonna see a
staggering effect on the labor market
economists that I've spoke to have said
they expect as many as 20 million jobs
could be lost to put that into
perspective less than 9 million jobs are
lost during the Great Recession look
deeper into the report and you'll find
more clues about the virus's impact 1.8
million people reported being on
temporary layoff and average hours
worked
week four thirty four point two which
was down from thirty four point four in
February wages meanwhile ticked up and
the reason for that is job losses
expected to be concentrated among lower
wage workers people that work at
restaurants people that work at hotels
temporary hires is usually the first
area to slow down or fall when the
economy is at a point of stress the
report is also subject to unusual
statistical distortions we're not so
sure about the surveys that underlie
this because many businesses were closed
or no one was in the office and if no
one's there to give the response it's
possible that numbers were depressed and
we're not getting a accurate picture and
some of the people who lost their jobs
may be counted as out of the labor force
rather than unemployed because they're
not actively seeking work at a time when
the virus has shut businesses the April
jobs report will be released May 8th and
that's going to give us even greater
insight into the effect from the corona
virus pandemic
it will likely capture that hundreds of
thousands if not millions of Americans
have been laid off and that the
unemployment rate could be skyrocketing
some economists say well into the double
digits